Et si les élections
européennes permettaient à Jordan Bardella
de s'émanciper de Marine Le Pen ?
En plus d'arriver en tête du scrutin,
il souhaite ouvrir 1 nouvelle page de l'histoire du RN.
Dans 1 interview au Figaro,
Jordan Bardella a officialisé
sa candidature aux
européennes de deux-mille-vingt-quatre.
Il a théorisé à cette occasion
le clivage des forces du renoncement
face aux partisans de la puissance.
Jordan Bardella
souhaite dépasser le clivage de deux-mille-dix-neuf
entre patriotes et mondialistes,
afin d'élargir l'électorat du RN
et convaincre les classes moyennes,
menacées de déclassement.
Après la dédiabolisation du RN
incarnée par Marine Le Pen,
Jordan Bardella
souhaite désormais être le visage de sa normalisation.
En l'invitant aux rencontres de Saint-Denis,
Emmanuel Macron lui a donné 1 sacré coup de pouce.
Au niveau européen,
le RN est allié à la Ligue de Matteo Salvini,
ouvertement prorusse.
Alors que Marine Le Pen souhaite rester
loyale à Salvini,
Jordan Bardella préférerait Sally à Giorgia Meloni,
qui est sur 1 ligne pro américaine. La Ligue,
liste complète du RN pour les européennes,
sera prochainement annoncé.
Jordan Bardella veut beaucoup de renouvellement.
Par rapport à deux-mille-dix-neuf,
il compte offrir les 2e et 3e place à des alliés.
1 sondage paru ce dimanche dans le JDD
place Jordan Bardella en tête avec 25% des suffrages,
devant la majorité présidentielle,
à vingt-et-un pour 100.
Les républicains et reconquêtes sont loin derrière,
avec respectivement 8 et 6,5%.